So let's discuss some examples of VLIW processor.
The most famous example of how to probably not
do VLIW is Intel's Itanium processors. It has
tons of ISA features that help the compiler schedule
code well, etcetera. As a result, the hardware
of the processor became very complicated. It no longer
needed to check for dependencies between instructions, but it
had so many other bells and whistles to do
this that the hardware is probably the most complicated
Intel ever belt. And yet fundamentally this is still
a VLIW processor, so it's still not doing great
on your regular code. Another example of where VLIW
is often used is DSP processors. What DSP stands
for, digital signal processing. Digital signal processing does a
lot of floating point work, typically in a very
regular loop with a very small amount of work within
each iteration and lots of, lots of iterations. So
typically, these types of processors on these types of
codes get excellent performance and are also very energy
efficient, because they don't spend much power on figuring
out dependencies and so on. So these are examples
of when we try to use VLIW for all
types of codes, we run into problems. But if
we find the type of codes where compilers can
do well, suddenly VLIW looks like a very, very good choice for that.